à 14 ans et un mois ils s'apprêtent à
passer le bac je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
me donnerait une épreuve d'entrée à
l'école normale ou en grandes écoles
je ne serai plus capable de la faire
2 me
[Musique]
pas qu'il ya eu classes prépas écoles
normales supérieures en mathématiques
je voulais être professeur de maths
professeur chercheur il y avait beaucoup
fait faire travailler plus que ce qui
sur l'intellect sur leur raison et
j'aime beaucoup faire mais les faire des
mathématiques résonner dans les
exercices en arrivant à l'école normale
je me suis aperçu qu'en fait c'était pas
forcément mon monde n'était pas
forcément les maths qui me faisait
vibrer le plus parce qu'en parallèle de
ça je vous ai des cours de théâtre de
piano de musique son histoire serait un
peu triste s'il n'avait d'autre passion
que l'école mais il aime le solfège le
violon le piano et il n'y a rien à faire
c'est plus fort que lui en musique comme
ailleurs il collectionne les premiers
prix
j'avais mon prix de piano j'étais très
intéressé par par par l'art du spectacle
est donc en arrivant à l'école normale
j'ai préféré m'occuper des activités
culturelles de l'école montrésor qu'être
monter des spectacles et en l'espace de
quelques années j'ai fait le choix de
complètement me tourner dans le monde du
spectacle vivant
et aujourd'hui je suis donc chef
d'orchestre metteur en scène et
producteur de spectacles